हेलो
हेलो हेलो
एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल
आफ्टर लॉन्ग टाइम
तो सबसे पहले मुझे बताइए सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है? प्लीज बताना क्योंकि
काफी टाइम बाद क्लास स्टार्ट करने के
बावजूद भी आज हमारा थोड़ा सा इश्यूज आ गया
था। माइक इशू आ गया था जो सॉफ्टवेयर का
इशू था। तो आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट। हमारा 20
मिनट वेस्ट हो गया। तो सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है।
ओके
ओके थैंक यू थैंक यू प्रणय एंड आफ्टर
लॉन्ग टाइम फिर से सेम स्टूडेंट देख के आई
एम हैप्पी और अगेन आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट
इतना लॉन्ग गैप के लिए
क्योंकि मेरी हेल्थ इशू था मैं सही नहीं
था मेरा गला खराब था बिकॉज़ ऑफ माय अह गले
की वजह से प्रॉब्लम हुई जिससे मैं बोल
नहीं पा रहा था। तो दैट इज व्हाई आई एम
नॉट एबल टू टेक द
क्लास। तो फिर से अब हम कंटिन्यू
करेंगे और आई प्रॉमिस कि हम जल्द से जल्द
उसको रिकवर करेंगे। जो हमने 14 डेज के
अंदर टू वीक के अंदर जो क्लासेस में कवर
करना था उसको हम जल्द से जल्द रिकवर करने
की कोशिश करेंगे। तो फिर से एक बार मुझे
बता दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
या नहीं दे रही और
प्लीज ज्वाइन कर लो
अभी और क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं हम।
ओके प्ल आई एम
फाइन क्लास को स्टार्ट करें फिर।
ओके तो हम क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं।
आपका टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे और हम अपने
स्लाइड पर चलते हैं। हम ये रहा ओके
तो काफी लॉन्ग गैप हो गया तो इसकी वजह से
हो सकता है कि जो कुछ आज नए स्टूडेंट्स हो
या प्रीवियस स्टूडेंट भी
टॉपिक को कंटिन्यू करने के लिए कोरिलेट ना
कर पाए या काफी भूल गए होंगे किसी ने
रिवीजन नहीं किया होगा ताकि हम सडनली अगर
बीच से टॉपिक को स्टार्ट करेंगे तो शायद
आपको अनकंफर्टेबल फील हो आपको क्लास में
मजा ना आए तो हम क्या करेंगे सबसे पहले डे
31 से लेकर डे 33 तक जो भी कुछ हमने पढ़ा
था उसको समराइज करेंगे। एक छोटी सी समरी
के रूप में उसको हम एक बार रिवाइज करेंगे।
सो दैट कि आपको पता चल जाए कि हमने
क्या-क्या पढ़ा था। इंपॉर्टेंट इंपोर्टेंट
चीजें सारी चीजें डिस्कस नहीं करेंगे। बट
जो जो भी कुछ पढ़ा था डे 31 से लेकर डे 33
तक हम उसको एक बार समराइज करेंगे। देन
उसके बाद जो आज का हमारा टॉपिक है डीएलएल
डायनेमिक लिंक लाइब्रेरी काफी छोटा सा
टॉपिक है। इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है तो फिर
उसको कंटिन्यू करेंगे क्योंकि स्टेप बाय
स्टेप चल रहे थे हम अह डे 31 से लेकर डे
30 तक हमने स्टेप बाय स्टेप अह बिल्कुल
ज़ीरो से हम धीरे-धीरे आगे बढ़ रहे थे और
सडनली लॉन्ग गैप होने की वजह से अगर मैं
बीच से टॉपिक को आपको पढ़ाऊंगा तो हो सकता
है कि कुछ चीजें आपको ऐसा लगा कि बोरिंग
दैट इज व्हाई हम अपने प्रीवियस सेशन को
समराइज करेंगे देन उसके बाद हम आगे बढ़ते
हैं
तो तो अभी क्लास को स्टार्ट करने के लिए
हम सबसे पहले बात करते हैं। हमने सबसे
पहले बात की थी कि Windows का बूटिंग
प्रोसेस थी उसके बारे में पढ़ा था हमने।
जो Windows की बूटिंग प्रोसेस थी उसके
बारे में पता पढ़ा था। उसके बारे में
थोड़ा सा मैं समराइज़ करता हूं। पूरा
डिटेल में नहीं बताऊंगा। बट
ओवरव्यू दूंगा आपको कि हमने बूटिंग
प्रोसेस में क्या-क्या पढ़ा था ताकि आपका
रिफ्रेश हो जाए मेमोरी। तो स्टेप वन में
मैंने आपको पढ़ाया था। जैसे ही आपने
सिस्टम को पावर ऑन किया तो पावर ऑन का जो
बटन था आपने प्रेस किया। प्रेस करते ही वो
एक सर्किट से कनेक्टेड रहता है। वो सर्किट
इंगेज हुआ। सर्किट इंगेज होते ही एक
सिग्नल गया आपके पावर सप्लाई यूनिट के पास
पीएसयू ने। अब पावर सप्लाई यूनिट के पास
जैसे ही सिग्नल गया तो सबसे पहले पावर
सप्लाई यूनिट थी जो आपका पीएसयू आपको अह
दिखाई दे रहा होगा। वह क्या किया उसने?
अपना सेल्फ टेस्ट किया। सबसे पहले क्या
किया? सेल्फ टेस्ट किया और जब एक बार उसका
सेल्फ टेस्ट ओके हो गया या सेल्फ टेस्ट
पास हो गया देन उसके बाद पावर जो पीएसयू
यूनिट थी पावर सप्लाई यूनिट थी उसकी भी
कुछ रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज थी उसकी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी क्या-क्या थी कि एसी
सिग्नल को डीसी सिग्नल में कन्वर्ट करना
क्योंकि मैक्सिमम जो भी इलेक्ट्रॉनिक्स की
चीजें चीजें होती हैं आपके मदरबोर्ड्स के
अंदर वो सारी की सारी डीसी पावर सप्लाई से
ही चलती हैं। उसके बाद क्या क्या करना जब
पावर सप्लाई स्टेबल है उसके बाद उसने क्या
किया उस पावर सप्लाई को पीएसयू यूनिट ने
आपके मदरबोर्ड को आपके सीपीयू को आपके रैम
को और जीपीयू और स्टोरेज एंड जो बाकी
पेरिफेरल डिवाइसेस जैसे आपके माउस है
कीबोर्ड्स हैं या आपके जैसे माइक लगा है
या अदर्स जो भी कंपोनेंट्स लगे हुए हैं जो
डिपेंड करते हैं आपके सीपीयू के ऊपर तो सब
में क्या करेगा पावर सप्लाई डिस्ट्रीब्यूट
करेगा और साथ के साथ ये इंश्योर करेगा कि
जो पावर है वो स्टेबल है इनके पास पास
जाने से पहले अभी जब पावर सप्लाई स्टेबल
है, सेल्फ टेस्ट कर लिया पीएसयू ने तो
पीएसयू ने एक सिग्नल भेजा आपके मदरबोर्ड
को पावर गुड सिग्नल। तो जैसे ही आपके
मदरबोर्ड को पावर गुड सिग्नल मिला तो आपके
मदरबोर्ड के पास क्या थे? वोल्टेज
रेगुलेटर्स थे। वोल्टेज रेगुलेटर ने क्या
किया? जितने भी कंपोनेंट थे उसके अंदर
मदरबोर्ड के अंदर GPU था, आपकी एसएसडी थी,
आपका जो प्रोसेसर था, आपकी रैम थी, सबको
क्या कर दिया? उसने पावर सप्लाई को
डिस्ट्रीब्यूट कर दिया। पावर सप्लाई को
भेज दिया। उसके बाद क्या हुआ? जब मदरबोर्ड
के अंदर पावर सप्लाई आ गई देन उसके बाद
क्या हुआ था? जो सीपीयू वेकअप्स एंड बीइंग
एग्जीक्यूशन आपका सीपीयू की वेकअप प्रोसेस
स्टार्ट हो गई और उसने एग्जीक्यूशन
स्टार्ट कर दिया। कहां से? एक स्पेसिफाइड
एक प्रीडफाइंड मेमोरी एड्रेस से वो मेमोरी
एड्रेस कहां पर सेट रहता है? आपका रिसेट
वेक्टर के अंदर। रिसेट वेक्टर के अंदर एक
प्रीडफाइंड एक प्रीसेट मेमोरी एड्रेस होता
है। जहां से आपका सीपीू पहली इंस्ट्रक्शन
फैच करता है। अभी यह जो प्रोसेस है सीपीू
के बैकअप से लेकर सीपीू के एग्जीक्यूशन
स्टार्ट करने तक यह काफी इंपॉर्टेंट
प्रोसेस होती है। अभी सीपीू की बैकअप
प्रोसेस में क्या होता है कि जब भी आपके
सीपीयू को पावर सप्लाई मिलती है तो
डायरेक्टली आपका सीपीू एग्जीक्यूशन
स्टार्ट नहीं करता। आपका सीपीू क्या करता
है? एक वेक अप और इनिशियलाइजेशन जो
प्रोसेस होती है उसके थ्रू गो थ्रू करता
है। उसके थ्रू जाता है। इसके कुछ फोर
स्टेप्स थे जो मैंने आपको बताया था कि
पावर ऑन सेल्फ चेक सीपीओ अपना जो पावर ऑन
सेल्फ चेक करेगा। देन उसके बाद रिसेट लाइन
एक्टिवेशन होगी। जब एक बार आपकी पावर
सप्लाई स्टेबल हो जाएगी। उसके बाद क्लॉक
सिंक्रोनाइजेशन देन उसके बाद जो रजिस्टर्स
और कैचे वैल्यू को क्लियर कर दिया जाएगा।
देन उसके बाद आपका सीपीू क्या हो गया? वेक
अप हो गया। जब एक बार आपके CPU को पावर
सप्लाई मिल गई और आपका जो इससे आपका रिसेट
लाइन से एक्टिवेट हो गया देन आपका CPU
क्या करता है अपने को क्लॉक को स्टेबलाइज
करने के बाद क्या करता है इंस्ट्रक्शन
एग्जीक्यूट करना स्टार्ट कर देता है कहां
से रिसेट वेक्टर रिसेट वेक्टर के अंदर एक
मेमोरी एड्रेस होता है जो किसको पॉइंट आउट
करता है आपके बायoस और यूएफआई चिप को
क्योंकि इसके अंदर जो एड्रेस होता है आपका
रिसेट वेक्टर के अंदर यह इसका बायoस या
uएफi चिप का एड्रेस होता है। ओके? और जो
पहली इंस्ट्रक्शन होती है वो कहां वो
किसको फैच जहां पे स्टार्ट करता है आपका
CPU बायoस या ईएफआई फ्रॉमवेयर जो
एग्जीक्यूशन है उसका एग्जीक्यूशन स्टार्ट
कर देता है। तो देन जब आप एक बार मदरबोर्ड
में सप्लाई हो गई CPU
आपका इंस्ट्रक्शन फैच करना स्टार्ट कर
दिया। देन उसके बाद आपका बायoस या यूईfआई
क्या है? आपका एग्जीक्यूशन स्टार्ट कर
लेता है। देन उसके बाद आगे चलते हैं हम।
स्टेप टू था आपका पावर ऑन सेल्फ टेस्ट।
जैसे ही आफ्टर प्रेसिंग द पावर ऑन बटन दी
पीसीज फ्रॉम वेयर इनिशलाइज ए पावर ऑन
सेल्फ टेस्ट। अभी मैंने आपको क्या बताया
था? जैसे ही आपने पावर ऑन बटन प्रेस किया
था तो स्टेप वन के अंदर इतनी सारी चीजें
हुई थी एक साथ। और वो किससे पहले हुई?
आपके पोस्ट पावर ऑन जो सेल्फ टेस्ट होता
है उससे पहले ये सारी चीजें हुई हैं। जब
वह सारी चीजें गुड कंडीशन में है वह सारी
चीजें अपना टेस्ट पास कर लेती है। देन
उसके बाद आपका पोस्ट टेस्ट स्टार्ट होता
है जो क्या करता है आपका पावर ऑन सेल्फ
टेस्ट करता है एंड लोड्स फ्रॉमवेयर सेटिंग
एंड द प्रीबूट प्रोसेस एंड व्हेन ए वैलिड
सिस्टम डिस्क इज़ डिटेक्टेड। देन थर्ड
स्टेप थर्ड स्टेप पे क्या होता है कि जो
आपका आफ्टर पोस्ट जो बायoस है या यूएफआई
है वो क्या करते हैं आपके बूट लोडर को
डिटेक्ट करते हैं। अब बूट बूट लोडर
डिटेक्ट का मतलब बूटिंग डिवाइस जो मेरा जो
मेरा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है कहां पर रखा हुआ
है? मुझे बूट कहां से करना है? हार्ड
डिस्क से बूट करना है या एसएसडी से बूट
करना है या USB से बूट करना है या सीडी या
डीवीडी से बूट करना है या आपके नेटवर्क से
बूट करना है। ओके जब एक बार उनको बूटिंग
डिवाइस मिल जाएगा देन द फर्मवेयर चेक द
बूट ऑर्डर कन्फ़िगरर्ड इन द बायस और यूएफआई
सेटिंग वंस ए बूटेबल डिवाइस इज फाउंड
कंट्रोल इज पास टू द बूट लोडर। जब एक बार
बूटिंग अह बूटिंग डिवाइस आपको मिल जाएगा
स्टेप थ्री के अंदर तो जो उसका कंट्रोल है
बूट लोडर को पास कर दिया जाएगा। अब बूट
स्टेप फोर में बूट लोडर क्या करता है कि
स्टेप फोर में बूट लोडर यह पता करता है कि
आपका अगर कौन सा बायोस यूज़ किया जा रहा
है? लेगसी बायोस या यूएफआई। इफ दिस सिस्टम
यूजज़ लेगसी बायोस इट रीड्स द एमबीआर
पार्टीशन फ्रॉम द हार्ड डिस्क। अगर आपका
जो सिस्टम्स है यूईएफआई बायoस यूज़ कर रहा
है तो उस केस में आपका जीपीटी पार्टीशन
रीड किया जाएगा किया जाएगा आपकी हार्ड
डिस्क से देन आपका ईएफआई बूट लोडर को
एग्जीक्यूट किया जाएगा डायरेक्टली
इनडायरेक्टली आपका बूट लोडर एग्जीक्यूशन
होगा ही होगा यहां पर देन स्टेप फाइव में
क्या होता है स्टेप फाइव में Windows बूट
मैनेजर आ जाता है कि बायoस क्या करता है
आपका फॉर एग्जांपल एमबीआर पार्टीशन को रीड
करता है व्हिच रीड द पार्टीशन टेबल लॉन्च
द बूट सेक्टर व्हिच देन स्टार्ट स्टार्ट
बूट मैनेजर exc एक फाइल को स्टार्ट करता
है। व्हेन बूट मैनेजर रंस देन इट एक्चुअली
रीड्स बीसीडी डॉटेड फाइल जब आपका एमबीआर
पार्टीशन जो बूट सेक्टर होता है आपकी
हार्ड डिस्क के अंदर जिसको हम एमबीआर
पार्टीशन के अंदर बूट सेक्टर होता है आपका
वहां पर एक बूट मैनेजर exc फाइल है। जैसे
उस फाइल को ल्च किया जाता है। वो क्या
करता है? सबसे पहले किसको रन करता है?
बीसीडी डॉट डेट फाइल है। इसको रन करता है।
अब यह क्या है? एक डेटाबेस है, एक
रजिस्ट्री फाइल्स है जिसके अंदर आपका जो
पीसी है बूट कैसे होगा? वह सारी की सारी
फाइलें इसके अंदर क्या की जाती है?
रजिस्ट्री फाइल के अंदर कॉन्फ़िगर की जाती
है। ओके? यहां पर आपके पीसी को बूट करने
की इंस्ट्रक्शंस होती है। स्टेप सिक्स में
क्या होता है? आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लोड
होता है। wिन
लोड.excd. फाइल स्टार्ट द Windows लोडर।
विन लोड exc ऑन द Windows बूट पार्टीशन
ओके देन जब आपका बूट लोडर विन लोड विन लोड
exc फाइल एग्जीक्यूट करती है तो इस तरीके
से आपकी स्क्रीन देखने को मिलती है स्टेप
सेवन में क्या होता है windows कर्नल
इनिशियलाइजेशन उसके बाद wिन लोड exc के
बाद noss कर्नलxc फाइल को एग्जीक्यूट किया
जाता है वो क्या करती है इट एसेंशियल
ड्राइवर्स रिक्वायर्ड टू स्टार्ट द
Windows कर्नल आर लोडेड एंड कर्नल स्टार्ट
टू रन लोड अकॉर्डिंग इनू मेमोरी द सिस्टम
रजिस्ट्री हाइव एंड एडिशनल ड्राइवर्स दैट
आर मार्क्ड एज बूटst। यहां पर क्या होता
है कि इस सिस्टम को स्टार्ट करने के लिए
जितनी भीेंट फाइल्स या जहां पर बूट
स्टार्ट के अंदर मार्क की गई है सारी फाइल
को स्टार्ट कर दिया जाता है। सारी
सेटिंग्स को या सारी सर्विज को लोड कर
दिया जाता है। या आपकी जो रजिस्ट्रीज हैं
इंपॉर्टेंट रजिस्ट्री फाइल्स हैं जो बूथ
टाइम पर आपके सिस्टम के अंदर लोड कर दी
जाती है। जब मैं रजिस्ट्री को पढ़ाऊंगा
काफी डिटेल में जब आपको बता दिया जाएगा कि
रजिस्ट्री क्या होती है। तो द कर्नल उसके
बाद एक बार कर्नल ने हार्डवेयर को
इनिशलाइज़ कर दिया। रजिस्ट्री को लोड कर
दिया और बूटst के अंदर जो जो फाइल थी या
जो जो कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस थी उनको आपके मेमोरी
के अंदर लोड कर दिया। देन उसके बाद कर्नल
क्या करता है? अपना कंट्रोल किसको? सेशन
मैनेजर को दे देता है। व्हिच इनिशियलाइज द
सिस्टम सेशन लोड्स एंड स्टार्ट द डिवाइस
एंड ड्राइवर्स। देन उसके बाद क्या था?
स्टेप एट में सेशन मैनेजर आता है। तो सेशन
मैनेजर सब सिस्टम इज ए क्रिटिकल विंडोज
प्रोसेस रिस्पांसिबल फॉर सेटिंग अप एंड
एनवायरमेंट फॉर यूजर मोड प्रोसेससेस। अभी
जो कर्नल मोड देखो आपको पता है कि दो मोड
होते हैं। एक तो कर्नल मोड, एक यूजर मोड।
अब कर्नल के बाद जो सबसे पहला जो यूजर मोड
के अंदर जो प्रोसेस रन करती है या जो
एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल रन करती है कर्नल के
बाद वह सबसे पहली फाइल या जो सबसे पहली जो
प्रोसेस वह कौन सी है आपकी? सेशन मैनेजर।
यह एस यह वाली प्रोसेस आपकी एग्जीक्यूट
करती है। इट इज द फर्स्ट यूजर मोड प्रोसेस
दैट रंस आफ्टर द Windows कर्नल हैज़
इनिशलाइज्ड। दिस सेशन मैनेजर प्लेज़ ए की
रोल इन हैंडलिंग सिस्टम वाइड टास्क बिफोर
यूजर लॉग इन। उसके बाद क्या करती है? जो
ये सेशन मैनेजर है, यह सेशन जीरो के अंदर
रन करता है। व्हिच इज द सिस्टम सेशन जहां
पर आपकी सर्विज और सिस्टम प्रोसेससेस रन
करती है। इसकी की रिस्पांसिबिलिटीज़ क्या
है? इनिशलाइज सिस्टम एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल्स
लोड द रजिस्ट्री सिस्टम हाई क्रिएट मैनेज
सिस्टम सेशंस स्टार्ट क्रिटिकल सिस्टम
प्रोसेससेस एंड कॉन्फ़िगर वर्चुअल मेमोरीज
देन उसके बाद आपके फाइनल स्टेट आता है बूट
प्रोसेस का अब जब एक बार सेशन मैनेजर ने
अपनी प्रोसेस को कंप्लीट कर लिया और
कंप्लीटली एग्जीक्यूट होगी दे आफ्टर द
इनिशलाइज़ेशन दी Windows लोग ऑन प्रोसेस
बिगेन जब Windows की जो लॉग ऑन प्रोसेस है
वो स्टार्ट होती है उसके दो कंपोनेंट होते
हैं wind logon exc Windows लॉग ऑन
एप्लीकेशन एक एलs.exc लोकल सिक्योरिटी
अथॉरिटी सब सिस्टम सर्विस ये दोनों एक साथ
स्टार्ट होती है क्योंकि सिस्टम के अंदर
लॉग इन करने के लिए हमें यूज ऑथेंटिकेट
करना पड़ेगा और ऑथेंटिकेट करने के लिए
आपकी लोकल सिक्योरिटी अथॉरिटी सब सिस्टम
सर्विस का यूज़ किया जाता है। व्हेन लॉगन
exc स्टार्ट्स द यूजर लॉग ऑन स्क्रीन
अपीयरर्स जैसे आपको देखने को मिल रहा है।
अप एससीएम सर्विस कंट्रोल मैनेजर स्टार्ट
सर्विज एंड एनी ग्रुप पॉलिसी स्क्रिप्ट
दैट आर नीडेड टू बी रन व्हेन द यूज़र्स लॉग
इन Windows क्रिएट ए सेशन फॉर दैट यूजर
उसके बाद सर्विज स्टार्ट हो जाती है।
ग्रुप पॉलिसीज या जो भी पॉलिसीज हैं
सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी उसको लोड कर दिया जाता
है। देन यूजर लॉग इन करता है। Windows एक
सेशन स्टार्ट कर देती है उस पर्टिकुलर
यूजर के लिए। देन जैसे ही आपका यूजर लॉग
इन करता है नेक्स्ट एक और प्रोसेस स्टार्ट
होती है एक्सप्लोरर.exc जो क्या होती है
आपकी? डेस्कटॉप मैनेजर होता है जो आपको
डेस्कटॉप देखने को मिलता है कि जहां पर
आपको जीआई देखने को मिलता है उसके लिए एक
प्रोसेस रिस्पांसिबल होती है कौन सी
एक्सप्लोरx तो ये चीज मैंने आपको Windows
की डे 31 में Windows बूटिंग प्रोसेस के
अंदर काफी आराम से काफी टाइम लेकर काफी
डिटेल में मैंने बताया था। यहां पर मैंने
उसका ओवरव्यू दिया है क्योंकि आप भूल गए
होंगे हमने अभी तक क्या-क्या पढ़ा है। दैट
इज व्हाई थोड़ा सा आज मेरे साथ बेयर
कीजिए। मेरे साथ साथ दीजिए क्योंकि रिवीजन
करवाना बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है कंटिन्यू
करने के लिए। तो यहां तक शायद सबको क्लियर
होगा।
यहां तक सबका क्लियर है? देयर आर ओनली 13
स्टूडेंट्स। इट्स ओके। नो इशू। सबको मेरी
आवाज तो आ रही है
ना? कोई इशू तो नहीं है आवाज के
साथ? नहीं किसके बारे में हम बाद में बात
कर सकते हैं। शायद सेशन के बीच में अगर
मैं यह सब डिस्कस नहीं करता। मैं अपना
सेशन
बिल्कुल ऑनेस्टली अपना सेशन लेता हूं।
ओके वॉइस क्लियर? ओके ओके थैंक यू। देयर
आर ओनली 13 स्टूडेंट्स। नो इशू। तो उसके
बाद हम कंटिन्यू करते हैं।
तो अभी नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पर चलते हैं। तो जब
भी आपने क्या किया? एक बार अपने सिस्टम को
ऑन कर लिया। एज ए बेसिक यूजर हम क्या करते
हैं? जैसे हमने पावर ऑन किया अपने सिस्टम
को अपने Windows मशीन को हम क्या करते
हैं? या तो हम एज ए बेसिक यूजर या तो हम
गेम प्ले करने के लिए गेम खेलने के लिए
उसको यूज करते हैं या ऑफिस वर्क जैसे कि
Microsoft ऑफिस के अंदर Microsoft Word के
अंदर या ईमेल करने के लिए या पीपीटी बनाने
के लिए सॉरी या अदर जो यूज़र्स की जो
रिक्वायरमेंट है ऑफिस की रिक्वायरमेंट है
वो फुलफिल करने के लिए हम यूज़ करते हैं।
कौन करते हैं या डेवलपमेंट करने के लिए
अगर आप डेवलपर हो या मूवीज़ देखने के लिए
Netflix देखने के लिए ब्राउजिंग इंटरनेट
के लिए जैसे Firefox Chrome इंटरनेट
एक्सप्लोर एक्सट्रा ये सारे काम करने के
लिए हम यूज़ करते हैं ना ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
को आई एम राइट आई एम राइट कि हम सब यही
यही काम करने के लिए यूज़ करते हैं ना
नॉर्मली तो एज ए बेसिक यूजर हम पीसीज को
ऑन क्यों करते हैं?
यही सब बेसिक यूजर्स हैं। अगर हम
इंडस्ट्री लेवल पर बात करेंगे तो सर्वर की
बात करेंगे तो हम सर्विज प्रोवाइड करने के
लिए अपनी मशीन को ऑन करते
हैं। इज इट राइट गाइस?
ओके। तो अभी हम बेसिक यूजर तो है
नहीं। अब हम बेसिक यूजर तो है नहीं। वी आर
ए साइबर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट और एज ए
साइबर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट अब हम बात करें
कि हमें यह पता होना चाहिए कि जो बेसिक
यूज़र्स है जो ये सारे काम परफॉर्म कर रहा
है वो काम ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पर कैसे डील
किए जाते हैं। हाउ दे आर वर्किंग ऑन दिस
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम एज ए साइबर सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट। इसका जवाब हमारे पास होना
चाहिए। इसीलिए हम पढ़ रहे हैं फंडामेंटल्स
ऑफ ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम या फंडामेंटल्स ऑफ
Windows। ओके? दैट इज व्हाई वी आर लर्निंग
द फंडामेंटल्स ऑफ Windows या फंडामेंटल्स
ऑफ ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम क्योंकि वी आर नॉट ए
नॉर्मल यूज़र्स। वी आर पेंटेस्टर्स या वी
आर ए साइबर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट और एज अ
साइबर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट अगर कोई आपसे
पूछता तो आपको इसका पीछे का लॉजिक पता
होना चाहिए। और दैट्स दैट्स व्हाई आई एम
लर्निंग दिस फंडामेंटल्स। तो मैंने आपको
यह भी बताया था। अब ये सारी चीजें किसके
थ्रू हो रही हैं? प्रोसेस के थ्रू हो रही
है। मैंने यह बताया था आपको कि जितने भी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस जितने भी प्रोग्राम्स या जो
भी एप्लीकेशन जो भी आप काम कर रहे हो एज ए
बेसिक यूज़र्स वो किसके थ्रू डील किया जा
रहा है आपके ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम में प्रोसेस
के थ्रू। तो मैंने डे 32 में और डे 33
दोनों का कॉम्बिनेशन में मैं आपको बताया
था कि प्रोसेस होता क्या है? प्रोसेस एक
वर्चुअलाइज कंटेनर है जहां पर आपकी सारी
की सारी एप्लीकेशनेशंस और सर्विज रन करती
हैं। उस कंटेनर को एक मेमोरी की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है। सिक्योरिटी की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है। थ्रेड्स की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है और आईपीसीस की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है। आईपीसी क्या होता
है? यह भी एक्सप्लेन कर चुका हूं। थ्रेड्स
क्या होता है? यह भी मैंने आपको बताया।
थ्रेड्स क्या होता है? वह एक्चुअल कोड
होता है जो
आपके कंटेनर के अंदर रन करता है। क्योंकि
प्रोसेस तो एक कंटेनर है लेकिन एक्चुअल
कोड्स क्या है? जो प्रोग्राम है वह क्या
आपका थ्रेड्स हैं। इसलिए सारी की सारी
एप्लीकेशन चाहे आप गेम खेल रहे हो, चाहे
कोई भी ऑफिस का काम कर रहे हो, डेवलपमेंट
कर रहे हो, वाचिंग मूवी, ब्राउजिंग,
इंटरनेट या आप आल्सो यू आर वर्किंग एज ए
एथिकल हैकर्स या आप पेन टेस्टिंग भी कर
रहे हो, उसके लिए कोई भी टूल रन कर रहे
हो, कुछ भी काम कर रहे हो वो वो सारा आप
किसके थ्रू कर रहे हो? प्रोसेस के थ्रू।
और प्रोसेस क्या है? एक वर्चुअलाइज्ड
कंटेनर। और इस कंटेनर को रन करने के लिए
मेमोरी, सिक्योरिटी, आईपीसी और थ्रेड्स की
रिक्वायरमेंट होती है। थ्रेड्स आपके वो
एक्चुअल कोड्स होते हैं जो आपके कंटेनर के
अंदर रन करते हैं। ओके? और आईपीसीस के
बारे में मैंने आपको बताया आईपीसीस क्या
होती है?
आईपीसीस सेट ऑफ रूल्स होते हैं जिसके थ्रू
एक एप्लीकेशनेशंस दूसरी एप्लीकेशनेशंस के
साथ सेम सेम नेटवर्क के अंदर सेम आउटसाइड
द नेटवर्क या सेम मशीन के अंदर कैसे डाटा
ट्रांसफर कर सकती है कैसे कम्युनिकेट कर
सकती है यह सारे के सारे रूल्स किसी भी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस के लिए डिफाइन किए जाते हैं
विद दी हेल्प ऑफ आईपीसी आईपीसी के बारे
में मैंने आपको यही बताया था आईपीसी वर्क
नॉट ओनली बिटवीन एन एप्लीकेशनेशंस फॉर
एग्जांपल माउस कर्सर रंस फ्रॉम वर्ड टू
पावर पॉइंट एंड इट्स कॉपिंग कंटेंट फ्रॉम
वर्ड टू पावर पॉइंट स्लाइड्स ओनली
एप्लीकेशन टू एप्लीकेशन ही काम नहीं करता
एप्लीकेशन टू सर्विस सर्विस टू
एप्लीकेशनेशंस या आपका एक नेटवर्क से
दूसरे नेटवर्क में भी कम्युनिकेशन करने के
लिए आपकी आईपीसी का यूज़ किया जाता है।
ओके? क्योंकि हर रोज डेली बेसिस पर हम कुछ
भी काम करने के लिए पीसी के अंदर ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के अंदर हम एप्लीकेशनेशंस को रन
करने के लिए डाटा शेयर करने के लिए या
एप्लीकेशन टू एप्लीकेशन कम्युनिकेट करने
के लिए हम आईपीसीस का यूज करते ही करते
हैं विदाउट आईपीसी वी कैन नॉट डू एनीथिंग
इंटू एन ए ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम और इंटू एन ए
प्रोसेस ओके तो सर सेम रूल्स आर अप्लाई
फ्रॉम एप्लीकेशन टू एप्लीकेशन सर्विस टू
एप्लीकेशन प्रोसेस टू प्रोसेस आईपीसीस
वर्क इवन अक्रॉस द नेटवर्क। यह चीज मैं
आपको बता चुका हूं। और ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के
अंदर हर एक चीज क्या है? एक प्रोसेस है।
एप्लीकेशन भी एक प्रोसेस है और सर्विज भी
आपकी क्या है? प्रोसेस के अंदर ही रन करती
हैं। ये चीज मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन कर चुका
हूं पहले ही। उसके बाद मैंने आपको क्या
बताया था कि देयर इज़ अ सिंगल फाइल
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर रंस ए प्रोसेस। दैट सिंगल
फाइल इज़ रिस्पांसिबल फॉर क्रिएटिंग दिस
वर्चुअल कंटेनर। अभी इस वर्चुअल कंटेनर को
क्रिएट करने के लिए या इस प्रोसेस को रन
करने के लिए एक सिंगल फाइल रिस्पांसिबल
होती है। इनके लिए कोई अलग-अलग फाइल नहीं
होती है। एक सिंगल फाइल रिस्पांसिबल होती
है जो इस वर्चुअल कंटेनर को क्रिएट करती
है। इस प्रोसेस को क्रिएट करती है। जैसे
Microsoft Word इज़ यूज़्ड बाय एवरीवन एंड द
प्रोसेस ऑफ़ Microsoft Word इज़ रन बाय ए
सिंगल फाइल कॉल्ड Win Word.exc एवरीवन
नोज़। दिस फाइल इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
क्रिएटिंग द विचुअलाइज्ड कंटेनर। इट सेट्स
अप ए मेमोरी एंड सिक्योरिटी। इट पुल द
मेनी मेनी अदर फाइल्स इनसाइड द विचुअल
कंटेनर। ओके? क्योंकि यही वो सिंगल फाइल
है जो एक कंटेनर क्रिएट करती है। उसके लिए
मेमोरी अलॉट अलॉट करती है। उसकी
सिक्योरिटी की देखरेख करती है। उसके बाद
फाइल को कैसे शेयर किया जाए सब कुछ किया।
उसके अंदर जो डीएलएल्स हैं या जो सर्विज
उसको रिक्वायरमेंट है जिन-जिन फाइल्स की
रिक्वायरमेंट है वो सारी की टेक केयर क्या
करते हैं? यही सिंगल फाइल रिस्पांसिबल
होती है उस चीज के लिए। तो दैट फाइल इज़
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर मेंटेनिंग द प्रोसेस
मॉनिटरिंग द प्रोसेस एंड टिरिंग डाउन द
प्रोसेस व्हेन इट रेडी। ओके? जब प्रोसेस
को अगर टर्मिनेट करना है तो उसके टरिंग
डाउन प्रोसेस के लिए भी यही सिंगल फाइल
रिस्पांसिबल होती है। यह चीज मैंने आपको
डे 32 में बताया था। नेक्स्ट अभी मैंने
आपको क्या बताया था? जब भी आप डबल क्लिक
करते हो किसी भी एप्लीकेशनेशंस के ऊपर तो
एक प्रोसेस क्रिएट हो जाती है। एक एक
वर्चुअलाइज़ कंटेनर क्रिएट हो जाता है। तो
सबसे पहले वो क्या करता है? जैसे ही वो
क्रिएट होते हैं तो किसके पास जाते हैं?
शेड्यूलर के पास। अब ये शेड्यूलर क्या
होता है? शेड्यूलर आपका क्या होता है?
कंट्रोलर होता है। जो क्या करता है? आपके
सीपीू को कंट्रोल करता है। कहने का मतलब
क्या है? फॉर एग्जांपल प्रोसेस 1 2 3 4 5
अप टू n ये सभी के सभी एक साथ मैंने क्लिक
किया और शेड्यूलर के पास की अभी शेड्यूलर
डिसाइड करेगा कि कौन सी प्रोसेस को कितने
नंबर ऑफ सल्स मिलेंगे कौन सी प्रोसेस कब
रन करेगी तो सबसे प्रोसेस वन आई उसको कुछ
नंबर ऑफ सेकंड कुछ माइक्रो सेकंड के लिए
नंबर ऑफ सल्स दिए सीपीू के रन एंड आउट रन
एंड आउट रन एंड आउट मैंने आपको यह बताया
था वो फिर से लाइन में लग जाएगी तो यही
पूरा प्रोसेस चलता है मैं आपको बता चुका
हूं जिसको इसको कॉन्टक्स्ट स्विचिंग बोलते
हैं। शेड्यूलर ऐसे ही प्रोसेस को शेड्यूल
करता है। लाइक दैट प्रोसेस वन आई कुछ
माइक्रो सेकंड रन किया देन अगेन फिर से
लाइन में लगी। प्रोसेस टू फिर लाइन में
थ्री फिर लाइन में फोर लाइन में क्योंकि
प्रायोरिटी सबकी सेम है। क्योंकि
हार्डवेयर की प्रायोरिटी हाई होती है। तो
अगर प्रोसेस वन रन कर रही है और उसके बीच
में अगर मैंने माउस मूव किया तो प्रोसेस
वन वेट सेम टाइम उसके ऊपर माउस माउस की जो
प्रोसेस है वह क्या करेगी? उसको सीपीू
साइकिल मिलेंगे। देन फिर से कंटिन्यू
प्रोसेस वन। इस तरीके से यह क्या करती
हैं? अपने वन बाय वन बाय वन वन सीक्वेंस
में चलती रहती है और ऐसा ही होता है। यह
इतना स्पीड से काम होता है गीगाHz की
स्पीड में हमें लगता है एक फ्लूइड मोशन
है। कंटीन्यूअसली रन कर रहा है। लेकिन यह
ऐसा नहीं होता। ये एग्जैक्टली जैसे मैंने
आपको बताया ऐसे होता है। जैसे आप डायग्राम
में देख पा रहे हो। क्योंकि आपका सीपीू
है। आपका प्रोसेसर इतना फास्ट रन करता है
जो आपकी आंखों को धोखा दे रहा है। बट हमें
जैसा लगता है कि जैसे हमने मूव
कर्सर को मूव किया। Chrome भी रन कर रहे
हैं।
हमारा विजुअल यह अपना ओबीएस स्टूडियो रन
कर रहा है। YouTube चल रही है। सारी चीजें
एक साथ चल रही हैं। बट वो काम ऐसे ही कर
रही हैं। लेकिन वो स्पीड इतनी फास्ट है
क्योंकि हमें लग रहा है कि यह आपके
कंटीन्यूअसली फ्लूइड मोशन में है। लेकिन
ऐसा नहीं है। और यह जो चीज हो रही है इसको
हम बोलते हैं प्रिमिटिव मल्टीटास्किंग।
टुडे ऑल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लाइक लinक्स, Mac
OS, iOS, Android, Windows आर प्रिमिटिव
मल्टीटास्किंग। इट मींस ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
हैज़ टोटल कंट्रोल ऑन द प्रोसेस हु गोज़ इनू
द CPU एंड हु हैज़ एक्सेस टू द सीpu टाइम।
किसको CPU के पास टाइम है, सीपीू एक्सेस
किसको मिलेगा, किसको नहीं मिलेगा? यह सारा
सारा कंट्रोल आपके ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के पास
है। और इस इस टाइप के ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को
बोलते हैं प्रिमिटिव मल्टीटास्किंग। जितने
के जितने आज के ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हैं सारे
प्रिमिटिव मल्टीटास्किंग ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
है। मैंने आपको बताया था देयर आर थ्री
टाइप्स ऑफ ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम रियल टाइम
प्रिमिटिव और कोपरेटिव। कोपरेटिव 20 से 30
साल पहले यूज़ किया जाता था। रियल टाइम
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम बहुत रेयर्स हैं। जहां पर
आपको रियली देखने को मिलेंगे न्यूक्लियर
रिएक्टर्स वगैरह के लिए। बट प्रिमिटिव
मल्टीटास्किंग आप यूज़ कर रहे होते हैं। ये
चीज मैं आपको डे 32 में मैंने आपको बताया
था।
अभी यह वही चीज है। प्रोग्राम वन,
प्रोग्राम टू, प्रोग्राम थ्री एज इट इज।
यह सबको पता है। एक्सप्लेन कर चुका हूं कि
एक बार कुछ फ्यू सीपीू सल्स प्रोग्राम वन
को मिलते हैं। फिर प्रोग्राम टू,
प्रोग्राम थ्री, फिर प्रोग्राम वन,
प्रोग्राम टू फिर ऐसे इस तरीके से आपके
सारे के सारे प्रोग्राम्स रन करते हैं।
चाहे प्रोग्राम्स आपके कितने भी हो। तो ये
चीज मैं आपको बता चुका हूं। ओके? यहां तक
सबको पता है। यहां तक हमने डे 31 से लेके
डे 33 तक पढ़ाया था। तो अभी मुझे बता
दीजिए किसी को यहां तक किसी का कोई पहले
से कोई सवाल था जो मुझसे पूछना चाहते हो
लेकिन हमारा माइक्रोफोन की इशू होने की
वजह से जो क्लास के 20 मिनट हमारे वेस्ट
हुए हैं
वो उसके कारण कुछ स्टूडेंट्स ना आए हैं।
किसी ने क्लास को छोड़ दिया है या मैंने
इसको समराइज किया है। अगले 10 मिनट में 20
मिनट में इसको मैंने कंप्लीटली समराइज कर
दिया कि अभी तक जो भी कुछ हमने पढ़ा है
ताकि अभी आप आगे नेक्स्ट जो पढ़ेंगे आप
इसको कोरिलेट कर
पाओ शायद क्योंकि डाउट नहीं होना चाहिए
था। तो अभी हम नेक्स्ट चलते हैं। नेक्स्ट
जो टुडे जो आज का डेट 34 का टॉपिक था कि
मैंने आपको बताया कि प्रोसेससेस एक
कंटेनर्स है। उसके अंदर दो ही टाइप के
सॉफ्टवेयर आपके क्या करते
हैं? रन करते हैं। ठीक है? इंसाइड
प्रोसेससेस बेसिकली देयर आर टू टाइप्स ऑफ
सॉफ्टवेयर। दो ही टाइप के सॉफ्टवेयर होते
हैं। एक तो सर्विज दूसरा क्या होता है
आपका? यूजर इंस्टॉल। अभी Microsoft
इंस्टॉल अबाउट 80% ऑफ द सर्विज दैट आर
रिक्वायर्ड टू रन एन
एप्लीकेशन। अब होता क्या है कि जब भी आप
क्या करते हो?
Microsoft Window को क्या करते हो?
Microsoft जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है Window
10, 11, 10 व्हाटएवर जब आप उसको इंस्टॉल
करते हो तो Microsoft इतना स्मार्ट है कि
80% ऑफ द सर्विज जो किसी भी एप्लीकेशनेशंस
को रन करने के लिए रिक्वायर्ड है उन
सर्विज को बाय डिफॉल्ट इंस्टॉल कर देता है
आपके ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के साथ ही। अब
सर्विज आर नॉट कंट्रोलोल्ड बाय यू। अब
सर्विज कभी भी आपके द्वारा कंट्रोल नहीं
की जाती। दे आर कंट्रोलोल्ड बाय द
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। अब ये सर्विज का जो
टॉपिक आएगा नेक्स्ट डे 35 की जो क्लास है
वो पूरी की पूरी सर्विज के ऊपर है। तो
उसमें आपको मैं एक्सप्लेन करूंगा कि
सर्विज क्या होती है? किसके द्वारा
कंट्रोल कैसे की जाती हैं। ओके? तो सर्विज
को कभी भी आप कंट्रोल नहीं करते। वो आपके
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के द्वारा कंट्रोल की
जाती है। और 80% ऑफ़ द सर्विज आपकी जब आपका
Microsoft ऑफ आपका Microsoft ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम इंस्टॉल किया जाता है। 80% ऑफ़ द
सर्विज को क्या किया जाता है? इंस्टॉल कर
दिया जाता है। तो रिक्वायर्ड है किसी भी
एप्लीकेशन को रन करने के लिए। अब दो ही
चीजें आपकी रन कर रही होती हैं आपके
प्रोसेस के अंदर। या तो सर्विज होंगी या
आपके यूजर इंस्टॉल्ड सॉफ्टवेयर्स होंगे।
अब यूजर इंस्टॉल्ड सॉफ्टवेयर कौन से होते
हैं? दोज़ आर इंस्टॉल्ड बाय द यूज़र्स। फॉर
एग्जांपल Chrome, Firefox, AOB, VLC या
अदर आपके गेम्स ये सारे के सारे क्या है?
आपके यूजर इंस्टॉल्ड सॉफ्टवेयर्स हो। तो
अभी मुझे मेरा एक सवाल आप लोगों से मैं
आपका चैट में आंसर का वेट करूंगा। डज
एनीवन नो यूजर इंस्टॉल सॉफ्टवेयर ऑलवेज
बिलोंग्स वेयर? जब भी आप किसी भी
सॉफ्टवेयर को इंस्टॉल करते हैं तो वह कहां
पर इंस्टॉल होते हैं?
बताइए कोई भी बताएगा।
ओनली एट
स्टूडेंट्स। आज तो हद कर दी यार। हम थोड़े
से लेट के आठ ही स्टूडेंट आए
आज। जब भी हम कोई भी सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल
करते हैं यूजर इंस्टॉल जैसे कि Chrome,
Firefox, AOB या VLC प्लेयर या इवन आपका
चाहे GT हो या व्हाटएवर गेम तो वह कहां पर
इंस्टॉल होते हैं? बाय डिफॉल्ट।
गुड पढ़ने प्रोग्राम फाइल्स के अंदर। ओके?
तो वह आपके देखने को मिलते हैं। यहां पर
जो जब भी लोकल डिस्क C के अंदर जाओगे आप
तो आपको Windows के अंदर ये रहा ये
प्रोग्राम नहीं उसके अंदर आपको प्रोग्राम
फाइल्स और प्रोग्राम फाइल्स एज इट इज़ 32
और 64 के बीच के यहां पर आपको सारे के
सारे सॉफ्टवेयर्स देखने को मिलते हैं। जो
भी सॉफ्टवेयर आप इंस्टॉल करते हो। यूजर
इंस्टॉल सॉफ्टवेयर की बात कर रहा हूं मैं।
अभी किसी को यह भी पता है डू यू डू यू डज
एनीवन नो व्हेन यू इंस्टॉल एनी सॉफ्टवेयर
कैश वेयर 90% ऑफ द कोड गोज़? किसी को पता
है जब भी आप सॉफ्टवेयर को इंस्टॉल करते
हैं 90% कोड कहां पर जाता
है?
बताइए। यह तो बता दिया कि आपको
प्रोग्राम्स फाइल्स के अंदर सॉफ्टवेयर
देखने को मिलता है।
बट एक जगह और है जहां पर यस
वेरी गुड मतलब ऐप डाटा के अंदर। अभी जो
90% ऑफ द कोड वह आपका किसके अंदर जाता है?
आपकी प्रोफाइल के अंदर। Microsoft के अंदर
एक ट्रेंड है। Microsoft सॉफ्टवेयर में एक
ट्रेंड चला रखा है। जब भी आप कोई भी
सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल करोगे। ठीक है? तो बाय
डिफॉल्ट दो जगह उसके कोड जाते हैं। एक तो
प्रोग्राम फाइल्स के अंदर, दूसरा आपके
प्रोफाइल के अंदर। क्यों? प्रोफाइल इज लॉक
टू यू। प्रोफाइल्स का क्या है? प्रोफाइल
आप तक ही सीमित है। क्योंकि यू आर द
अथॉरिटी फॉर दैट प्रोफाइल। अकॉर्डिंग टू
एनटीएफएस सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी ओनली यू हैव
राइट टू योर प्रोफाइल। और आपकी प्रोफाइल
पर सिर्फ आपको ही राइट है या जो
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स हैं उनको राइट है। आपकी
प्रोफाइल को सिर्फ दो ही लोगों को या तो
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हो या फिर आप ही को ही
राइट है आपकी प्रोफाइल के अंदर। इसलिए बाय
डिफ़ॉल्ट जब भी आप कोई भी सॉफ्टवेयर
इंस्टॉल करते हो तो वह उसके जो कोड्स हैं
उसके जो प्रोग्राम्स फाइल्स हैं वो दो जगह
जाती हैं। एक तो आपकी प्रोफाइल फाइल के
अंदर दूसरी जाती है आपकी प्रोग्राम फाइल्स
के अंदर। आपको यकीन नहीं होता तो मैं आपको
शो कर देता हूं प्रैक्टिकली।
सॉरी तो यह मेरा राइट क्लिक सी यह
प्रोग्राम फाइल्स हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल देखिए
यह सॉफ्टवेयर आपको देखने को मिल रहे हैं।
अभी मैं विंडो आर करता हूं और ये परसेंटेज
ऐप डाटा परसेंटेज ओके अभी यहां पर देखिए
सेम ही तो है। लगभग ये 1
मिनट यह रहा
देखिए लगभग सारे सेम मिलेंगे।
AOB और देखिए यह रहा।
लगभग लगभग देखो रोड वीएम वसा ज़ूम
ठीक है तो लगभग सारी चीजें मिलेंग इसके
अंदर अब कुछ जो होंगे एडमिन लेवल के होंगे
जो इस इसके लिए नहीं होंगे तो वो तो अलग
है देखिए देखो लगभग बब स्वीट ओबीएस
स्टूडियो ठीक है तो सारी सारी चीजें आपको
देखने को मिल रही है ओके तो दोनों जगह
आपका कोड देखने को मिलता है
ओके। तो आपको पता चल गया जब भी आप कोई भी
सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल करते हो तो उसका कोर्स
कहां पर इंस्टॉल होता है? दो जगह पर। एक
तो आपकी प्रोफाइल के अंदर, दूसरा आपके
प्रोग्राम्स फाइल्स या आपके किसके
अंदर? यूजर प्रोफाइल के अंदर। अभी एज ए पे
पेंटेस्टर्स आपको किसी की यूजर प्रोफाइल्स
की ऐप डाटा का एक्सेस मिल जाए। वेरी गुड।
क्योंकि
उसके अंदर जो भी सॉफ्टवेयर रन कर रहे
होंगे उसके ऊपर उसके राइट्स हैं। ओके?
उसके अंदर उसके राइट्स हैं और वो उसके
हिसाब से काम कर सकते हैं। तो दैट इज़ दैट
इज व्हाई आई एम टेलिंग यू कि आपका जो
सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल होता है उसके अकॉर्ड दो
जगह जाते हैं। ओके? तो नेक्स्ट अभी हम बात
करते हैं कि जो थ्रेड्स है और प्रोसेससेस
है उनमें डिफरेंस क्या है? कि जो थ्रेड्स
हैं और प्रोसेस है उनमें डिफरेंस क्या है?
प्रोसेससेस आर इंडिपेंडेंट। आपकी जो
प्रोसेस है वो इंडिपेंडेंट है। जबकि आपके
थ्रेड्स हैं वो प्रोसेस के अंदर एक्सिस्ट
करते हैं। यह सबको पता है। प्रोसेससेस हैव
सेपरेट एड्रेस स्पेस। जबकि जो थ्रेड्स है
शेयर देयर एड्रेस स्पेस। प्रोसेस का जो
एडर स्पेस है, वह सेपरेट होता है। जबकि जो
थ्रेड्स हैं, वह प्रोसेस के एडर स्पेस को
शेयर करते हैं। प्रोसेससेस डू नॉट शेयर
एडर स्पेस। जो प्रोसेससेस हैं, वह कभी भी
एडर स्पेस को शेयर नहीं करते।
प्रोसेससेस इंटैक्ट ओनली थ्रू सिस्टम
प्रोवाइडेड आईपीसी मैकेनिज्म। अभी जो
प्रोसेस है एक प्रोसेस दूसरे प्रोसेस के
साथ अगर इंटैक्ट करना चाहती है तो वो
आईपीसीस का यूज करती हैं। जबकि उनके लिए
रूल डिफाइन किए गए
हैं। जबकि जो थ्रेड्स के लिए ऐसे कोई भी
रूल्स डिफाइन नहीं किए गए हैं। ओके? जैसे
प्रोसेससेस के लिए डिफाइन किए गए हैं।
कॉन्टक्स्ट स्विचिंग बिटवीन थ्रेड्स इन द
सेम प्रोसेस इज टिपिकली फास्ट देन
कांटेक्ट स्विचिंग बिटवीन द प्रोसेस।
कॉन्टेक्स्ट स्विचिंग क्या होता है?
शेड्यूलर से आपको सीपीओ टाइम मिला उसके
बाद आपको आउट कर दिया गया तो वो होता है
आपका कॉन्टेक्स्ट स्विचिंग। अभी आपको
प्रोसेस टू प्रोसेस प्रोसेस के बीच में
अगर कॉन्टेक्स्ट स्विचिंग करनी है तो
उसमें टाइम लगता है रेदर देन अगर आपके एक
प्रोसेस के अंदर जो थ्रेट्स है थ्रेड्स के
बीच में अगर कॉन्टेक्स्ट स्विचिंग करनी है
वो फास्ट होता है। तो दीज़ आर द फोर टू
फाइव डिफरेंसेस कि अगर आपको कोई पूछता है
कि थ्रेड्स और प्रोसेस में क्या डिफरेंस
है? तो आप आसानी से बता सकते हो कि
थ्रेट्स ये होता है। ये इसकी लिमिटेशंस
है। प्रोसेस ये होती हैं। ये इसकी
लिमिटेशंस हैं या ये इसकी एडवांटेजेस हैं।
थ्रेट्स हैं। ये इसकी एडवांटेजेस हैं। तो
आई थिंक क्यू क्लियर। सबको पता चल गया कि
थ्रेट्स और प्रोसेस में क्या डिफरेंस
है। आप यहां से भी कंटिन्यू कर सकते हो या
डे 31 से सर बिल्कुल आप डे 31, डे 32, डे
33 तो बिल्कुल ही पढ़िए आप।
ओके। तो अभी हम चलते हैं नेक्स्ट। हैंडल्स
क्या होते हैं? किसी को पता है हैंडल्स
क्या होते हैं? अब
हैंडल्स इन कंप्यूटिंग हैंडल्स आर
एब्स्ट्रैक्ट रेफरेंसेस यूज्ड बाय एन
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम टू मैनेज रिसोर्सेज। आपके
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर रिसोर्सेज को
मैनेज करने के लिए उनके उनको एज ए रेफरेंस
यूज करने के लिए हैंडल्स का यूज किया जाता
है। हैंडल्स इज नॉट द एक्चुअल ऑब्जेक्ट बट
ए यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर। एक रेफरेंस है असाइन
बाय द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम टू रिप्रेजेंट एन
ऑब्जेक्ट। फॉर एग्जांपल
थिंक ऑफ इट लाइक ए टिकट नंबर एट ए सर्विस
डेस्क। यू डोंट इंटैक्ट विद द सिस्टम
डायरेक्टली। यू शो योर टिकट दैट इज कॉल्ड
हैंडल्स एंड सिस्टम फाइंड द राइट
रिसोर्सेज फॉर यू। लाइक आप एक सर्विस
टैक्स से आपने टिकट ली है तो आपको
डायरेक्टली किसी से इंटक्ट करने की जरूरत
नहीं है सिस्टम के साथ। आप एक काम कीजिए
अपनी टिकट शो कीजिए और उस टिकट के अगेंस्ट
जो भी रिसोर्सेज आपके हैं आप टिकट आपकी
सीट के लिए भी हो सकती है। टिकट किसी भी
चीज के लिए हो सकती है। तो उस टिकट के
अगेंस्ट आपके जो भी रिसोर्सेज हैं आपको
प्रोवाइड कर दिए जाएंगे। ऐसे ही इसमें
हैंडल्स होते हैं कंप्यूटर के अंदर कि
आपको एक यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर प्रोवाइड कर
दिया जाता है और जब भी आप उसको अपने
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को शो करते हो तो उसके
अगेंस्ट जो भी रिसोर्सेज हैं आपको
प्रोवाइड कर दिए जाएंगे। ओके? इंस्टेड ऑफ
डायरेक्टली एक्सेसिंग मेमोरी एड्रेस
एप्लीकेशनेशंस यूजज़ हैंडल्स इंटेक्ट विद
ऑब्जेक्ट्स। ओके? अभी डायरेक्टली मेमोरी
एड्रेस को एक्सेस करने के बजाय जो
एप्लीकेशनेशंस होती हैं, वह क्या करती
हैं? हैंडल्स का यूज करती हैं अपने
ऑब्जेक्ट्स के साथ इंटैक्ट करने के लिए।
अब ऑब्जेक्ट्स क्या है? ऑब्जेक्ट्स आपके
रजिस्ट्री कीज़ भी हो सकती हैं। आपके
फाइल्स या फोल्डर्स भी हो सकते हैं। आपके
ग्राफिकल ऑब्जेक्ट्स भी हो सकते हैं या
आपके इवेंट्स भी हो सकते हैं। कुछ भी हो
सकता है आपके ऑब्जेक्ट्स। अब इनके साथ
इंटरेक्ट करने के लिए आपकी एप्लीकेशनेशंस
क्या करती है? डायरेक्टली इनके मेमोरी
एड्रेस को एक्सेस करने के बजाय वो हैंडल्स
का यूज़ करती है। हैंडल्स क्या है? यूनिक
आइडेंटिफायर्स है। जस्ट लाइक ए टिकट। आप
टिकट शो करो और आपको इनमें से जो भी चीज
चाहिए आप उसका रेफरेंस आपको मिल जाएगा। तो
दैट इज कॉल्ड हैंडल्स। हैंडल्स सबको समझ
में
आया? किसी को कोई डाउट है कि हैंडल्स क्या
होते
हैं?
एवरीवन सबको हैंडल्स समझ में आ गए?
ओके अभी हम बात करते हैं डीएलएल्स के बारे
में जो हमारा आज का टॉपिक है
डीएलएल्स डायनेमिक लिंक
लाइब्रेरीज व्हाट आर डीएलएल्स डीएलएल्स
होते क्या है
देखिए नाउ ऑल ऑफ यू नो हु इज देंट दैट
इंश्योर स्टेबिलिटी एंड विचुअलाइज कंटेनर
सबको पता है कि सबसे ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट
कौन है कि जो आपकी स्टेबिलिटी और
विचुअलाइज कंटेनर को क्या करते हैं?
इंश्योर करते हैं। क्या है सभी को पता
है? एवरीवन नोज़ कि जो आपकी विचुअलाइज
कंटेनर प्लस में उसकी स्टेबिलिटी को
इंश्योर करते हैं। जो सबसे ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है उनका नाम क्या है? उनको आप
क्या
बोलोगे? नो सर।
अरे क्यों डिसपॉइंट कर रहे हो? अभी तक एक
ही चीज तो मैं आपको पढ़ा रहा
हूं। विचुअलाइज कंटेनर प्लस में उसकी
स्टेबिलिटी को मेंटेन करने के लिए जब आपने
हिस्ट्री पढ़ी थी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की तो
एक ही तो टर्म आपके सामने आई
थी। स्लाइड को देख के आंसर क्यों कर रहे
हो?
मैंने आपको पूछा हु इज देंट दैट इंश्योर
स्टेबिलिटी एंड विजुअलाइज कंटेनर
ओनली इतना पूछा आगे मत जाओ
यहां पर दो सवाल
है
बताइए दैट
इंश्योर स्टेबिलिटी एंड विचुअलाइज कंटेनर
यह इंश्योर कौन करता
आप लोगों ने वही काम किया
कि पूरी रात आपने रामायण देखा सुबह बोलते
हो रामायण के बारे में पूछते हो फिर कि
कौन क्या
था दैट इज नॉट एक्सेप्टेबल
बताओगे या नहीं
बताओगे? देखता हूं आप कितने लोग आज आंसर
देते हो। तो इससे मुझे पता चल जाएगा कि आप
लोग कितना फोकस्ड वे में पढ़ रहे हो या
जस्ट यू आर पासिंग पासिंग योर टाइम इन माय
क्लासेस। आई डोंट नीड सॉरी
डे 31 से लेकर आज भी मैंने उस चीज को
पढ़ाया
है। हु इज देंट दैट इंश्योर स्टेबिलिटी
एंड विचुअलाइज कंटेनर?
हाइपरवाइजर
वाह एक काम कीजिए रिकॉर्डिंग देखिए जितने
भी स्टूडेंट्स हैं क्लास को छोड़ दो लीव
इट नाउ
लीव इट
नाउ मैं बोल रहा हूं मत आया करो क्लास में
एक अच्छी इतनी अच्छी समरी आपको प्रोवाइड
की है इस टॉपिक को पढ़ाने के लिए। फिर भी
आपने से सिंपली सॉरी
लीव द क्लास। मैं आपको रिकॉर्डिंग सोशन
प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा। बेटर बेटर रहेगा आपके
लिए। सिंपल सा आंसर है प्रोसेस। प्रोसेस
इंश्योर स्टेबिलिटी एंड विचुअलाइज कंटेनर।
प्रोसेस प्रोसेस प्रोसेस मैं यह तो पढ़ा
रहा हूं आपको।
भाई प्रोसेस ही तो है। वर्चुअलाइज कंटेनर
क्रिएट करती है। प्लस में उसकी स्टेबिलिटी
को मेंटेन करने के लिए क्या हुआ था? इससे
पहले एक एप्लीकेशन दूसरे एप्लीकेशन के कोड
को क्रैश कर देती थी। ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के
कोड को क्रैश कर देती थी। उस चीज को
मेंटेन करने के लिए कांसेप्ट आया था
प्रोसेस। वही तो है। स्टेबिलिटी एंड
विचुअलाइज कंटेनर को इंश्योर कौन करता है?
प्रोसेस।
नहीं बताया था क्या मैंने आपको प्रोसेस के
बारे
में
बताइए क्या प्रोसेस के बारे में नहीं
बताया
था आई विल नॉट टेक एनी क्वेश्चन फ्रॉम यू
ओके
देन नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन बट एक्चुअली हु डज
ऑल द वर्क्स अभी ओके कि प्रोसेस आपकी
स्टेबिलिटी और विचुअलाइज कंटेनर को मेंटेन
करती है इंश्योर करती है बट एक्चुअल में
इन सबके लिए काम कौन करता है ये सारे काम
किसके द्वारा किए जाते हैं किसके थ्रू किए
जाते हैं ये सारे काम आपके डीएलएल के थ्रू
किए जाते हैं इसका आंसर तब आया था अब
डीएलएल होता क्या है डीएलएल ए डायनेमिक
लिंक लाइब्रेरी इज अ शेयर लाइब्रेरी इन
विंडोज दैट कंटेन कोड डेटा एंड रिसोर्सेज
दैट मल्टीपल प्रोग्राम्स कैन यूज़
समन्यूसली। ओके? अभी जो डीएलएल्स हैं,
डीएलएस को आप बोल सकते हो शेयरर्ड
लाइब्रेरीज। वह लाइब्रेरी फाइल्स जिसके
अंदर कोड्स हैं, डाटा है या वह रिसोर्सेज
हैं जो किसी भी प्रोग्राम्स को रन करने के
लिए यूज किए जाते हैं और मल्टीपल
प्रोग्राम्स एक साथ इन डीएल्स को यूज कर
सकते हैं। मैंने आपको बताया था कि Windows
ने इस तरीके से डिजाइन किया हुआ है अपने
Microsoft को कि आपको एग्जांपल दिया था
देर 20 200 300 प्रोसेस में ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम में रन कर रही है। देखिए ये रहा
फिर
बोलोगे नाउ देखिए परफॉर्मेंस दे यहां पर
देखो परफॉर्मेंस परफॉर्मेंस
प्रोसेससेस परफॉर्मेंस ना मेमोरी सीपीयू
देखिए 266 प्रोसेस रन कर रही हैं और
थ्रेड्स और हैंडल्स देखिए हैंडल्स हैंडल्स
1442000 इतने इनके अंदर डीएल्स भी होंगे
आपके प्लस में क्या होंगे? आपको दिखाऊंगा
मैं। आपके डीएल्स भी होंगे, आपकी फाइल्स
भी होंगी, सब कुछ होगा। ओके? तो, यह होते
हैं आपके डीएल्स। डेल्स के अंदर आपके कोड
होता है, डाटा होता है, रिसोर्सेज होते
हैं जो साइमलटेनियसली एक साथ मल्टीपल
प्रोग्राम के अंदर यूज किए जा सकते हैं।
इंस्टेड ऑफ डुप्लीकेटिंग द सेम
फंक्शनैलिटी इन द मल्टीपल एग्जीक्यूटेबल
फाइल्स विंडोज स्टोर द रयूजेबल कोड इन ए
डीएलएल व्हिच एप्लीकेशनेशंस कैन एक्सेस
डायनेमिक लीड ड्यूरिंग रन टाइम। अभी होता
क्या है कि एक अभी जो मल्टीपल्स
प्रोग्राम्स होते हैं उनकी कुछ कॉमन
फंक्शनैलिटी होती है। कुछ कॉमन कोड्स होते
हैं जो सेम काम करते हैं। तो उस चीज को
क्या है कि बार-बार यूज़ करने की बजाय आपके
कोड को अच्छा बनाने के लिए और आपके कोड को
बार-बार ना यूज़ करना पड़े। उसकी लेंथ ना
बढ़ाने की बजाय उन्होंने क्या किया? जो
कॉमन कोड्स है, कॉमन डेटाज़ है, कॉमन
रिसोर्सेज को डीआरएल की फॉर्म में डिज़
करके आपके ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम में पहले से ही
रख दिया। आपको सिंपली क्या करना है? उसका
रेफरेंस लेना है और उसको यूज़ करना है।
जिससे क्या होगा? आपका एक तो प्रोसेसिंग
पावर फास्ट होगी। आपकी एप्लीकेशन फास्ट रन
करेगी। दूसरा आपके कोड की लेंथ भी कम
होगी। दैट इज व्हाई वी आर यूजिंग
डीएलएल्स। डीएलएस वो शेयर लाइब वो कॉमन
लाइब्रेरीज है जो मल्टीपल प्रोग्राम्स एक
साथ यूज़ कर सकते हैं। देयर आर टू
फंडामेंटल कैटेगरीज़ ऑफ़ डीएलएल्स। दो
फंडामेंटल कैटेगरीज होते हैं। 90% ऑफ़ द
डीएलस आर विंडोज़। 90% जो डीएलएल्स होते
हैं आपके वो Windows के होते हैं। दे आर
डिज़ बाय Microsoft क्रिएटेड बाय Microsoft
अपडेटेड बाय Microsoft जिनको Microsoft के
द्वारा ही डिजाइन किया जाता है। Microsoft
के द्वारा ही क्रिएट किया जाता है और
Microsoft के द्वारा ही अपडेट किया जाता
है। ओनली स्मॉल अमाउंट ऑफ डीएल्स आर
जनरेटेड बाय एन एप्लीकेशन डेवलपर। बाकी जो
10% बच गए वो एप्लीकेशन डेवलपर के द्वारा
डेवलप की जाती है, जनरेट की जाती है।
लेकिन 90% ऑफ द डीएलस Microsoft के द्वारा
डिजाइन किए जाते हैं। और उन्हीं डीएलस की
जो अदर जो थर्ड पार्टी जो एप्लीकेशनेशंस
है वो भी क्या है? Microsoft के डीएल का
ही यूज करती हैं। उनकी एपीआई कॉल करके
उनके डीएल्स को यूज कर सकती हैं। ओके? अभी
देखिए यह सारे डीएल्स हैं। आप कैसे फाइंड
आउट करोगे? कैसे? देखो मैं आपको दिखाता
हूं। सिंपली
हम यह आपके डीएलएस हैं। सारे के सारे
डीएलएस हैं।
देखो आपको सिंपली गो टू
योर वेज वेज स्क्रीनशॉट के बाद इसको हम
बैक करते हैं। देन वेज माय के सी यह रहा।
आपको सिंपली यहां पर क्या करना है? स्टार
और
डीएलएस देखो और हिट एंटर कर देना है। अभी
सर्च होने दो। देखो मेरे कोने में यहां पर
नोटिस करना। कितने डीएलएसल्स हैं अभी
देखना अभी काउंट हो रहे
हैं। इट विल टेक टाइम। यहां पे अराउंड
मेरी मशीन में टोटल फोर या 5000 डीएलएल्स
हैं। ठीक है ना? ये सारे के सारे आपके
Microsoft के द्वारा मैक्सिमम Microsoft
वाले डीएलएल मिलेंगे। देखो यहां पर देयर
आर
3982 डीएल्स फाइल्स हैं मेरी मशीन के अंदर
और ये सारा का सारा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम आपका
यही है। सारी सारी एप्लीकेशन सारे सारे
प्रोग्राम्स इन्हीं कॉमन 3982 डीएल्स का
यूज़ करते हैं रन करने के लिए। इस तरीके
डिजाइन किया गया है। अगर आपको देखना है
प्रैक्टिकली यह भी मैं आपको दिखा दूंगा।
हम चलो ये भी मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं। तो
एक चीज देखिए गो टू योर प्रोसेस टास्क
मैनेजर आपको टास्क मैनेजर पे दिखा देता
हूं कैसे जाओगे राइट क्लिक टास्क
मैनेजर और यहां
देखो व्यू एक
मिनट परफॉर्मेंस पे जाना है रिसोर्स
मॉनिटर अब रिसोर्स मॉनिटर की ये विंडो है
क्लिक करना है यहां पर आप देखो प्रोसेससेस
को देखो एक बार यहां पर कौन-कौन सी
प्रोसेससेस हैं अब मैं सबसे पहले आपको
Chrome दिखाता हूं। यहां पर Chrome Chrome
यहां पर Chrome सर्च करते हैं। यह रहा
दिखाई दे रहा होगा। हम हम Chrome Chrome
का इधर सर्च करते हैं। देखो इसको क्लिक कर
लेते हैं। Chrome की जितनी भी प्रोसेस है
ना सबको क्लिक कर लेते हैं। देखो Chrome
Chrome इतने सारे Chrome हैं। हमने
सेलेक्ट कर लिया। देखो
यहां पर इसके बाद आपको क्या करना है इसको?
सिंपली इतना क्लज़ कर दीजिए। यहां पर आपको
क्या करना है? है सीपीओ के अंदर जाना है।
क्लिक करना है। सर्विज आपको देखनी नहीं
है। ओके? एसोसिएटेड हैंडल्स आपको देखने
नहीं है। यहां पर देखिए एसोसिएटेड मॉडल्स
1 2 3 4 5 अभी यहां पर देखो। यहां पर
ध्यान से देखो। मैं इसको अभी क्लोज कर
देता हूं। इतना यहां पर देखो जितने भी
Chrome Chrome क्या है? यह Chrome की
प्रोसेस है जो हम Chrome ब्राउज़र यूज़ कर
रहे हैं। तो यहां पर देखो ध्यान से
डीएलएल्स ये आपके डीएलएल्स यूज़ किए जा रहे
हैं। देखो ये डीएलएल्स। यहां पर आपको पता
चल जाएगा कितने Chrome के होंगे। यह रहा 1
2 3 4 5 Chrome की प्रोसेस खुली है। जिनके
सिर्फ ओनली Chrome के इतने ही है। थर्ड
पार्टी है ओनली 10% बाकी देखो Microsoft
DL सिस्टम 32 ये रहा डीएलएल। यह रहा सारे
के सारे Microsoft के DL यूज़ किए जा रहे
हैं। देखो सारे के सारे Microsoft के DL
देखो सिस्टम 32 के अंदर यह रहा ऑल आर द
Microsoft DL यह लाइव आपकी मशीन के अंदर
यूज़ किए जा रहे हैं। लाइव
यह देखो यहां पर कुछ कुछ ही बिल्कुल 10%
है जो आपके कौन से
होंगे? आपके थर्ड पार्टी होंगे। दूसरी
प्रोसेस आपको दिखा देता हूं। चलो मैं इसको
क्लोज करता हूं। एंड यह तो Chrome
थी। यह रहा। इसको हम हटा देते हैं। अभी हम
जैसे कि सिस्टम प्रोसेस नहीं चाहिए हमें।
क्रॉस
एंड एंड एंड एंड एंड यह रहा कोई भी कोई भी
प्रोसेस देख लेते हैं इधर
डिफेंडर नहीं नहीं नहीं अरे
यार कोई तो रुको एसर एसर की प्रोसेस है
इसको एक काम के
देखो इससे रिलेटेड देखो ये सारे डीएल ये
भी देखो Microsoft के डीएल मैक्सिमम
Microsoft के डीएल देखो सर के प्रोसेस डॉट
ये रहा देखो सारे के सारे अब टै पीकेजी
कुछ लोकल्स हैं इसके अलग हैं। देखो बट
सर्विस नेटिव अदरवाइज सारे के सारे डीलर
आपके Microsoft के डीलर हैं। तो इस तरीके
से डायरेक्टली और इनडायरेक्टली आपकी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस एक मल्टीपल्स एप्लीकेशनेशंस
सेम डीएलएल का ही रीयूज करती है। समझ में
आ गया डीएलएस की कहानी ऑल ऑफ यू क्लियर
डीएलएल सबको समझ में आ गया यहां तक सबका
क्लियर
है? अभी आप इसमें कुछ नहीं कर सकते। आपको
बताऊंगा ना डीएलएस को कौन छेड़ सकता है
कौन नहीं कर सकता। ठीक है? डीएलएस के आपके
जो डाउट्स हैं बचे हुए मैं क्लियर कर
दूंगा। अभी यहां तक क्लियर है कि अगर आपको
डीएलएस देखने हैं तो कैसे देख सकते
हो? एवरीवन गॉट क्लियर। ओके नेक्स्ट अभी
एक सवाल होगा आपका जो आपने अभी सोचा था कि
हाउ डू आई नो माय डीएल आर राइट वर्जन? कि
जो मेरे जो डीएलएल्स यूज़ किए जा रहे हैं
मेरी मशीन के अंदर उनका जो वर्जन है वह
अपडेटेड वर्जन है, लेटेस्ट वर्जन है या
सही वर्जन है? आउटडेटेड तो नहीं है। हाउ
डू आई नो दैट सम एप्लीकेशनेशंस हैज़ टू कम
इन एंड ओवराइट ए माइक्रोसॉफ्ट DLs एंड नाउ
इट्स आउट ऑफ डेट एंड इट वुड नॉट वर्क विद
अदर एप्लीकेशनेशंस। यह मुझे कैसे पता
चलेगा कि कोई भी एक एप्लीकेशनेशंस आई थर्ड
पार्टी एप्लीकेशनेशंस जिसने Microsoft के
जो डीएल्स हैं उनको ओवराइट कर दिया और अब
वो आउट ऑफ डेट हो गए और दूसरी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस के साथ वो काम नहीं कर रहे।
ये आपके दोस्त बहुत बड़े सवाल हैं जो आपने
कभी सोचे नहीं होंगे। अगर सोचे होंगे तो
इसका आंसर मैं अभी करूंगा कि सबसे पहले कि
मुझे कैसे पता चलेगा कि मेरा जो डीएल है
उसका राइट वर्जन कौन सा है? सही वर्जन कौन
सा है? इसकी मुझे चिंता करनी भी चाहिए या
नहीं करनी चाहिए या उसकी चिंता कौन करता
है? दूसरा सवाल ये है कि ओके आपने बोला कि
90% ऑफ द डीएलएसल्स Microsoft के हैं।
बाकी जो थर्ड पार्टी जितनी भी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस आप यूज़ करते हो कोई भी
एप्लीकेशन वो 10% खुद का डीएलएसल्स हो
सकता है। बाकी Microsoft के डीएलs को ही
यूज़ करते हैं। तो क्या ऐसा पॉसिबल है कि
कोई एक थर्ड पार्टी एप्लीकेशनेशंस आई उसने
Microsoft DLs को ओवराइट कर दिया और उसको
आउट ऑफ डेट बना दिया और बाकी अदर
एप्लीकेशन के साथ वह काम नहीं कर रहे। यह
दोनों के यह दोनों सवाल आपके हो सकते हैं।
यह दोनों सवाल आपके हो सकते हैं या नहीं
हो सकते?
हो सकती है
ना? तो हम क्या
करेंगे? तो अभी मैं आपको वो चीज समझाने के
लिए कुछ चीजें और बताता हूं। देखो मल्टीपल
एप्लीकेशनेशंस रिलाई ऑन द सेम डीएलएल्स।
एंड इंश्योरिंग करेक्ट वर्जन एंड
प्रिवेंटिंग अनऑथराइज्ड ओवराइट्स इज
क्रिटिकल फॉर सिस्टम स्टेबिलिटी। अभी यह
सबको पता है कि मल्टीपल्स एप्लीकेशनेशंस
होती हैं। वो सेम डीएलएल के ऊपर डिपेंडेंट
हैं। अभी अगर वह सेम डीएल फाइल के ऊपर
डिपेंडेंट है तो उनका जो वर्जन है वो भी
करेक्ट होना चाहिए और वो अन ऑथराइज्ड
ओवराइड से भी प्रोटेक्टेड होना चाहिए। और
यह स्टेप काफी क्रिटिकल स्टेप्स है। काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप्स है Microsoft के लिए
किसी भी सिस्टम्स के लिए। अगर क्या होगा?
इफ एन इनकरेक्ट और आउटडेटेड डीएल्स वर्जन
इज इंस्टॉल्ड अगर बाय मिस्टेक या जो आपका
सवाल था सवाल नंबर दो कि अगर आपका एक
इनकरेक्ट और आउटडेटेड डीएल्स आ गया तो
क्या होगा? इट कॉज एप्लीकेशन क्रशेस ड्यू
टू मिसिंग और चेंज फंक्शनंस कि आपकी
एप्लीकेशन क्रैश भी कर सकती है। दूसरा लीड
टू सिक्योरिटी वनेबिलिटीज इफ एन होल्डर्स
या वनेबल डीएलस इज लोडेड रिजल्ट इन
इनकंपैटिबिलिटीज इफ ए प्रोग्राम्स
एक्सपेक्टेड डिफरेंट वर्जन। ओके। अभी इसके
सरकमस्ट्ससेस क्या है कि अगर इसकी
सिक्योरिटी को अच्छे से मैनेज नहीं किया
गया या इनकरेक्ट या आउटडेटेड डीएलएल्स
आपकी मशीन के अंदर है उसकी वजह से आपकी
एप्लीकेशनेशंस क्रैश भी हो सकती है या
आपकी आपके अंदर एक सिक्योरिटी वन्टिटी
रहेगी ओल्डर वर्जन के कारण। दूसरा कि आपके
जो प्रोग्राम्स है वह इनकंपैटिबल्स होंगे
जो जिस तरीके से उनको काम करना चाहिए उस
तरीके से हो सकता है ना काम कर पाए या उस
पर्टिकुलर डीलर की वजह से आपका प्रोग्राम
हैक हो जाए। यह सारे क्रिया क्राइटेरियाज
हैं। तो अभी आगे हम आगे बढ़ते हैं कि इसके
लिए माइक्रोसॉफ्ट इनवोक ए यूटिलिटी कॉल्ड
Windows फाइल
प्रोटेक्शन। समझ में आया कि आपके जो दो
सवाल थे कि राइट वर्जन प्लस में कोई थर्ड
पार्टी एप्लीकेशनेशंस उसको ओवर ना कर पाए।
उसके लिए Microsoft ने एक यूटिलिटी डिजाइन
की जिसका नाम था Windows फाइल प्रोटेक्शन
डब्ल्यूएफपी। इसमें क्या था? नो वन कैन
ओवराइट दी डीएल। इन डीएलएल्स को कोई भी
ओवराइट नहीं कर
सकता। Windows फाइल प्रोटेक्शन मॉनिटर
सिस्टम्स डीएलएल्स एंड प्रिवेंट अन
ऑथराइज्ड मॉडिफिकेशंस। जो आपका Windows
फाइल प्रोटेक्शंस है जो सिस्टम्स के डीएल
है उसको मॉनिटर भी करता है और अनऑथराइज्ड
मॉडिफिकेशन से भी प्रोटेक्ट करता है। इफ ए
नॉन माइक्रोसॉफ्ट प्रोसेस ट्राई टू
रिप्लेस ए सिस्टम डीएलएल्स तो Windows
फाइल प्रोटेक्शन रिजेक्ट द रिप्लेसमेंट
एंड रिस्टोर द ओरिजिनल फाइल एंड लॉक द
इवेंट इन द इवेंट व्यूअर। क्या होता है कि
अगर कोई नॉन माइक्रोसॉफ्ट प्रोसेस है वो
इन डीएलएसल्स को रिप्लेस करने की कोशिश
करती है तो जो Windows फाइल प्रोटेक्शंस
है उसको रिजेक्ट कर देता है और फिर से
रिस्टोर कर ले रिस्टोर कर लेता है उस
ओरिजिनल फाइल को और उसका जो लॉग है वो
आपके इवेंट के अंदर इवेंट व्यूअर के अंदर
लॉक करके रख लेता है उसको उसमें मार्क कर
लेता है एक लॉक जनरेट कर देता है उसके
अगेंस्ट देयर इज ओनली वन पर्सन ऑन योर
पीसी हु हैज़ द अथॉरिटी टू ओवराइट योर
विंडोज फाइल। आपके सिस्टम के ऊपर आपके
पीसी के ऊपर एक ही ऐसा व्यक्ति है जिसके
पास यह अथॉरिटी है कि वो इन डीएलएल्स को
ओवराइट कर पाए या Windows फाइल की फाइल को
ओवराइट कर पाए। किसी को पता है? कोई गेस
कर सकता है?
बताइए। कोई भी गेस कर सकता है?
एनीवन नहीं एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर तो बहुत बच्चा
है। Windows में एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर के पास
ज्यादा पावर नहीं
है।
नो
देखिए वो है आपको। आप क्या
करोगे? दिस पीसी के अंदर जाओ। सी ड्राइव
के अंदर जाइए। उसके बाद Windows के अंदर
बूट के ऊपर मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं। देखो
गो टू योर सी ड्राइव दिस पीसी सी ड्राइव
windows बूट राइट क्लिक उसके बाद
प्रॉपर्टीज के अंदर जाइए प्रॉपर्टीज यह
खुल गया गो टू सिक्योरिटी टैब गो टू एडिट
टैब देखिए दिस वन ट्रस्ट ट्रस्टेड
इंस्टॉलर यही वो अकेला यूज़र्स है जो क्या
कर सकता है नहीं पावर सेल भी नहीं यही
अकेला यूज़र्स है जो Windows फाइल को क्या
करता
है या Windows के जो यह डीएल फाइल को
मॉडिफाई अपडेट डिलीट छेड़छाड़ कर सकता है।
ओनली यही है ट्रस्टेड
इंस्टॉलर आप इसको एक्सेस नहीं कर
सकते। समझ में आया? आपका इवन
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स कुछ नहीं कर सकता। ओके?
यही वाला यही कर सकता
ओनली। एक्सेस Microsoft के पास
है। Microsoft ने बनाया
ना Windows 8 के 10 से सारी की सारी
मैक्सिमम क्या है? यह मशीनें क्लाउड टाइप
की हैं। Windows 10, 11 जितना अच्छा
इंटरनेट मिलेगा उतने अच्छे से काम करती
हैं। इंटरनेट कनेक्शन स्लो रहेगा या
इंटरनेट सही से नहीं मिलेगा तो यह अच्छे
से काम भी नहीं करती आपकी Windows। दैट इज
द
रीज़ यह ओके समझ में आया चीज? ट्रस्टेड
इंस्टॉलर आई थिंक यह सबको पता चल गया। यही
अकेला यूजर है जो क्या कर सकता है? इनके
साथ छेड़छाड़ कर सकता
है। हां, ऑटो अपडेट होता रहता है ना। तभी
तो कभी आपने डीएलएस खुद से अपडेट किए हैं?
नहीं किए। क्यों? क्योंकि आपको जरूरत ही
नहीं पड़ी पड़ी Microsoft के अंदर। एक और
चीज बता देता हूं आपको। जब भी आप क्या
करते हो? फॉर एग्जांपल आपने क्या किया?
विंडो के ऊपर गए और यह Microsoft स्टोर के
अंदर से कभी आपने कोई सॉफ्टवेयर एप्लीकेशन
डाउनलोड की है? कोई भी सॉफ्टवेयर कोई भी
एप्लीकेशन आपने डाउनलोड की है Microsoft
Windows से इससे Microsoft Store
से की है ना? तो Microsoft स्टोर से जब भी
आप कोई भी एप्लीकेशन क्या करते हो इंस्टॉल
करते हो तो उस एप्लीकेशन की वो सारी की
सारी जो फाइल कहां पर जाएंगी? कैसे उनके
फोल्डर्स को हाइड किया जाएगा? कौन सा
डीएलएस अपडेट है? यह सारी चीजें किसके
द्वारा की जाती है? आपके इसी यूजर के
द्वारा। इसी यूजर के द्वारा मैनेज किया
जाता
है। इसी यूज़र्स के द्वारा ऑटोमेटिकली कि
उसकी फाइल प्रोग्राम फाइल के अंदर जानी
चाहिए। प्रोफाइल यूजर के अंदर जानी चाहिए।
यह डीएलएल्स हैं। यह अपडेट है या नहीं है।
यह डीएलएल मॉडिफाइड है या ये सारी चीजें
मैनेज किस की जाती है? ऑटोमेटिकली
ट्रस्टेड इंस्टॉलर के
द्वारा। समझ में आया? कुछ था ना यह चीज
आपको Windows की ऐसी चीजें बताऊंगा ना जो
आपने कभी सोची नहीं होंगी। यू नेवर थिंक
अबाउट अबाउट इट। वो तो थोड़ा सा लास्ट
स्टार्टिंग के 20 मिनट्स मेरा क्या था कि
डीमोटिवेट हो गया था बिकॉज़ ऑफ माइक्रोफोन।
मुझे लग नहीं रहा था कि माइक्रोफोन आज काम
करेगा। दैट इज व्हाई स्टार्टिंग है 20
मिनट्स में। आप लोगों को भी आप लोगों को
लगा कि सर आज की क्लास ऐसी
है। बिल्कुल कंट्रोल है ट्रस्टेड इंस्टॉलर
के पास फुल कंट्रोल।
ओके।
ठीक है? इसलिए व्हेन Microsoft स्टार्टेड
Windows Vista देन Microsoft एडेड ए न्यू
स्पेशल ग्रुप कॉल्ड ट्रस्टेड इंस्टॉलर।
दैट इज द पर्सन हु अलाउस माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
अपडेट्स हु अलाउस एनी Windows फाइल टू बी
ओवर रिटन अपडेटेड या चेंज वर्जन एटसेट्रा
एंड नो वन हैव कंट्रोल ऑन इट गेटिंग माय
पॉइंट यही एक ऐसा ग्रुप है जो सारे
Microsoft के अपडेट करता है। सारी उसकी
फाइल को ओवराइट कर सकता है। अपडेट कर सकता
है। उसके वर्जन को चेंज कर सकता है और
इसके ऊपर किसी का भी कंट्रोल नहीं होता।
ओके।
क्लियर क्लियर यहां तक
ओके
ओके तो आगे चल
तो नेक्स्ट बात करते हैं अभी व्हाई एज ए
पेंटेस्टर डील्स आर सोेंट
ओके इसका जवाब देने से पहले मैं आपको एक
और चीज दिखा देता हूं। एंड एंड एंड एंड एज
ए पेंटेस्टस का जवाब देने से पहले हम
डेल्स के बारे में हम गो टू
योर यह रहा इंटरनल्स एंड यहां पर भी आपको
दिखा देता हूं मैं एक और टूल्स है। ओके गो
टू डाउनलोड डायरेक्टरी
एंड स इंटरनल सूट
एंड यह मैंने एक दिन आपको बताया था और आप
देख सकते हो यह रहा प्रोसेस प्रोसेस
रन एंड
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स एक्स ऑफ
भाई मुझे आपका सवाल समझ में नहीं आ रहा आप
क्या पूछना चाह रहे हो ठीक है ये देखिए
अभी फॉर एग्जांपल्स ये रहा किसी भी
प्रोसेस का मैं क्या कर सकता हूं देखो
मैंने यहां पर क्लिक किया इसके द्वारा
कितने डीएल देखो नंबर ऑफ़ DLs देखो यहां पर
डिस्क्रिप्शंस DL कौन सा DLS है? किस
कंपनी का DLs है? और देखो यह रहा
Microsoft Microsoft किसी भी प्रोसेस पर
चले जाओ देखो। इसके द्वारा भी क्या है?
Microsoft Microsoft ये सारे DLs हैं।
देखो ये रहा Microsoft Microsoft हर जगह
डीएल्स डील किए जा रहे हैं। यही है टोटली
आपका जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम रन कर रहा है।
सारी एप्लीकेशन जो रन कर रही हैं उनमें
डीएल्स का ही यूज़ किया जाता है। देखो
डीएलएल्स यह रहा। देखो डीएल्स। अगर आप
हैंडल्स पे जाओगे तो हैंडल्स में और भी
ज्यादा इनफेशन देखो कौन सी डायरेक्टरी कौन
सी फाइल फुल पाथ के साथ देखो थ्रेड्स यह
रहा ओके जैसे ये रहा हम चलते हैं
नेक्स्ट ये रहा देखो कि फाइल व्हाटएवर ये
रहा देन अब इसके डीएलएस की इनेशन देखनी है
आप डीएलएस की इनेशन देख सकते हो थ्रेड्स
है तो थ्रेड्स की इनेशन देख सकते हो और एक
और चीज है कि आप यह जो कलर कोडिंग है ना
इस कलर कोडिंग का एक मोटो है कि किस कलर
का मतलब क्या है? देखो, आप यह देखना चाहते
हो गो टू योर ऑप्शन टैब समझने के लिए
कॉन्फ़िगर कलर।
देखो, अभी जो आपका ग्रीन रहता है, यह न्यू
ऑब्जेक्ट के लिए होता है। यह डिलीटेड
ऑब्जेक्ट के लिए आपको इस तरीके से कलर
मिलेगा। खुद के प्रोसेस के लिए कलर
मिलेगा। यह रहा देखो ऑन प्रोसेस इस यूज़र्स
की। सर्विज के लिए यह रहा लाइट पिंक।
सस्पेंडेड सर्विस के लिए यह रहा देखो
सस्पेंडेड सर्विज के लिए डार्क ग्रे पर्पल
पैक्ड इमेज के लिए रीलोकेटेड डीएलएल के
लिए और डॉट नेट प्रोसेस के लिए यह कलर
देखने को मिलेगा देखो कहीं पर आपको देखने
को प्रोटेक्टेड प्रोसेस के लिए आपको पिंक
देखने को मिलेगा इमर्सिव प्रोसेस के लिए
यह देखो तो यह कलर कोडिंग है जो आप देख
सकते हो ओके यह भी देख सकते हो ओके ओके
ओके अप्लाई देखो यह सारे देख सकते हो यहां
पर देखो यह डीएलएस के
ये रहा ये रहा ये रहा सारे कलर्स आप यहां
देख सकते हो। तो दिस इज़ द बेस्ट टूल्स फॉर
एनी ट्रबल शूटर्स। जिसको Windows की ट्रबल
शूटिंग करनी है तो आप इस टूल्स की हेल्प
से कर सकते हो। ज्यादातर यूज़ किया जाता है
आपके आईटी एडमिन के द्वारा। ट्रबल शूटिंग
टीम के द्वारा। सबको समझ में आ गया यहां
तक? क्लियर है?
यहां तक क्लियर है सबको?
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है?
अभी हम बात करते हैं कि एज ए पेंटेस्टस
डीएल्स के बारे में पढ़ना क्यों
इंपॉर्टेंट है? क्यों हमें डीएलस के बारे
में पढ़ना था और हमारे लिए डीएलएल्स क्यों
इंपॉर्टेंट है? एज ए पेंटेस्टस। ओके? तो
एज ए पेंटेस्टस हम बात करें तो एज ए
पेंटेस्टर्स डायनेमिक लिंक लाइब्रेरीज आर
सोेंट फॉर मल्टीपल रीज़ंस। प्राइमरली ड्यू
टू देयर रोल्स इन Windows मॉडल एनवायरमेंट
आर्किटेक्चर। ऑब्वियसली क्योंकि सबसे
ज्यादा डीएल्स का यूज़ किया जा रहा है
Windows के अंदर। तो इसलिए यह तो सबसे
प्राइम टारगेट और सबसे मोस्ट वैल्यूएबल
रीजन हो सकता है ना हमारे लिए कि डीएलस के
बारे में पढ़ना क्योंकि हर एक चीज तो
डीएल्स है और अगर आप इस पे अटैक करने में
सक्सेस हो जाते हो तो यू कैन कॉम्प्रोमाइज
द विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
ओके तो मोस्टली डीएलएल के ऊपर आप यह कुछ
हाई लेवल्स जो आपने सुने होंगे डीएलएल
हाईजैकिंग डीएलएल इंजेक्शंस पर्सिस्टेंस
वाया मलेशियस डीएल या प्रिविलेज प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन आप कर सकते हो डीएलएल की हेल्प
से। ओके? डीएल हाई जैकी की बात करें। देयर
आर अ लॉट ऑफ़ एप्लीकेशनेशंस हु डायनेमिकली
लोड्स डीएलएल एट रन टाइम बाय सर्चिंग फॉर
देम इन स्पेसिफिक डायरेक्टरीज। ओके? अभी
क्या है कि बहुत सारी ऐसी एप्लीकेशनेशंस
है जो रन टाइम पर डीएलएल को लोड करती है
पर्टिकुलर स्पेसिफिक डायरेक्टरी के अंदर।
किसको सर्च करके। इफ एन एप्लीकेशन डज नॉट
वैलिडेट द ऑथेंटिसिटी ऑफ़ द लोडेड डीएलएल
एन अटैकर कैन रिप्लेस इट विद ए मिलिशियस
डीएलएल। ओके? और अपना मिलसियस कोड
एग्जीक्यूट कर सकता है। हम डीएलएल
इंजेक्शन की बात करें बाय इंजेक्टिंग ए
मिलसियस डीएलएल इनू ए रनिंग प्रोसेस अलाउ
अटैकर टू एग्जीक्यूट कोड विद इन द
कॉन्टेक्स्ट ऑफ़ दैट
प्रोसेस। पर्सिस्टेंस की बात करें। अटैकर
कैन अचीव पर्सिस्टेंस बाय रिप्लेसिंग और
मॉडिफाइंग लेजिटमेट डीएल दैट एप्लीकेशन
लोड एट द स्टार्टअप कि आपका मलेशियस डीएल
को इंजेक्ट भी कर सकता है या आपके किसी भी
डीएलएस को मॉडिफाई या अकॉर्डिंग टू देयर
परमिशंस यहां पर सब कुछ खेल परमिशंस का
परमिशंस के बेस पर ही होगा आपके पास वैलिड
परमिशंस होनी ही चाहिए उस पर्टिकुलर फाइल
को मॉडिफाई करने के लिए और आप सक्सेस होगे
तो आप डील इंजेक्शन भी कर सकते हो डील
हाईजैकिंग भी कर सकते हो और पर्सिस्टेंस
भी कर सकते हो वाया मलेशियस डीएल और
प्रीलिजिलेशन भी कर सकते हो। ये सारे सारे
आप अटैक परफॉर्म कर सकते हो। तो दैट इज द
टॉपिक फॉर टुडे डीएलएल्स और आई होप सबको
समझ में आ गया होगा डीएलएल्स होते क्या है
और काफी डीप में मैंने आपको बताया कि
डीएलएल्स ही आपका टोटली ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
ही आपका डीएलएल के ऊपर काम करता है। तो
डीएलs के बारे में आपको अच्छे समझ में आ
गई होगी और डीएलएसल्स को कौन प्रोटेक्ट
करता है और डीएलएल्स को कौन ओवराइट कर
सकता है? कौन ओवराइट नहीं कर सकता। ये सब
मैंने चीजें आपको बता दी और एज ए
पेंटेस्टिस हमारे लिए डील पढ़ना क्यों
जरूरी है? यह भी मैंने आपको बता दिया है।
शायद थ्योरी प्लस प्रैक्टिकल्स हो गया
होगा। सबको क्लियर है यहां
तक? अभी तक के नोट अपडेट हो गए हैं
एप्लीकेशनेशंस के अंदर और आज के जो नोट्स
हैं वो शायद कल अपडेट करवा दूंगा मैं। तो
आई होप और नेक्स्ट जो टॉपिक रहेगा डे 35
आपका सर्विज के बारे में रहेगा। तो आप
किसी का कोई सवाल है तो मुझसे पूछ सकते
हो।
भाई गोपी मुझे आपका क्वेश्चन ही समझ में
नहीं आ रहा कि आप वीडियो के द्वारा कैसे
उसका इंफॉर्मेशन निकाले? आई डोंट नो। आप
क्या किस चीज के बारे में पूछ रहे हो मुझे
नहीं पता।
तो आपके पास एडमिन लेवल का एक्सेस होना
चाहिए। उन फाइल को डिलीट करके पल अप और
उसके बाद जो फाइल अननेसेसरी है पहले
Google पे सर्च कीजिए Microsoft के अंदर
कि जो मोस्टेंट फाइल्स कौन सी है आपके सी
ड्राइव के लिए उसके बाद उनको छोड़ के बाकी
को डिलीट कर दो फोर्सफुली एडमिनिस्ट्रेट
एडमिन प्रिज के साथ
लेकिन बूट फाइल नहीं डिलीट कर पाओगे। बाकी
चीजें कर सकते
हो। किसी का कोई सवाल है आज की क्लास से
रिलेटेड? मुझे पता है थोड़ा सा मेरी साइड
से डिले हुआ है और ड्यू टू टेक्निकल रीज़ंस
और ज्यादा कुछ नहीं।
ड्यूरल हाईजैकिंग और इंजेक्शन कैसे कर
सकते हैं? तो यह मेरे एडवांस कोर्स का
पार्ट है। और इस कोर्स का पार्ट नहीं है।
बट अगर आप मेरे साथ जुड़े रहोगे एडवांस
कोर्स सीखो तो वहां पर डीएल हाईजैकिंग भी
सिखा दी जाएगी क्योंकि प्रोजे एस्केलेशन
में डीएल हाईकिंग भी सिखाई जाती है मेरे
द्वारा।
तो सेशन को एंड करें
फिर। हां, यह यह इससे आप देख सकते हो ना?
यह अभी आपके सामने टूल ओपन किया।
ये तो कमांड भी होती है। कमांड सर्च
मारो। तो ओके हम सेशन को एंड करते हैं। तो
शायद आपका कोई सवाल नहीं है। तो बाय-बाय
एंड थैंक यू। टेक केयर एंड सी यू फॉर
नेक्स्ट सेशन। जल्दी मिलते हैं सेशन 35
में और नए टॉपिक के साथ। तब तक के लिए आप
डे 31, डे 32, डे 33 और डे 34 की खास करके
डीएल वाली सीरीज को रिवाइज कर लीजिए
क्योंकि इन फ्यूचर्स आपको बहुत काम आने
वाली है। यह ओके बाय-ब थैंक यू। टेक केयर
गुड नाइट।